shits Creek airs its final episode
tonight the show will say goodbye after
six seasons and it's actually gonna sign
off the same day today April 7th that is
the day that they started shooting the
show six years ago yeah so it's part of
the farewell that Kasim's has been going
about instagram live and doing it as a
fundraiser for people that have been
affected by Coppa 19 now last night the
Queen herself
Catherine O'Hara words from the
dictionary as motor rose and then she
ended things with a certain crow call
and we will hold each other and we will
suavi eight I'd never be obliteration
and pass Akane and an axe aphelion once
again it will rule the day so a v8 of
course is kiss publication a plague
Eurasian is excessive spending on food
and drink
pikas paese bonnie pai z z OG oh and why
is
[Music]
heavy padding love play love play that's
a nicer way of saying it a little lactea
now and then the lap t is a a a very
crowd of tea party in which guests sit
on each other's laps can you imagine
such a thing the way we're living now it
will happen again a lap t okay
I'm losing it her
thank you not even any words to
accurately describe that but that is
what you hope if you hope that you gave
your IG to Catherine O'Hara that's what
would happen with it well the funny
thing is like she's not on social media
I don't know her she might not even know
what Instagram live it's like how it was
gonna work like I'm sure that's probably
definitely the first time she's had to
kind of carry one to read the comments
that are coming in so I'm sure it was
interesting last May I loved for seeing
her do that I love to like I find a lot
of the time actors are nervous about you
know kind of improvising and playing
their iconic role because there's no
writing behind them right yeah there's
the same line so you should just being
that character off the top of her head
but her yeah just to sit there with
words like she's pulled weird words
she's pulled from the dictionary and
just kind of improvised his words just
amazing
I know and it is the reaction on social
was incredible to that and I think a lot
of that has to do with fans are all
hyper emotional about the show wrapping
up but I think that it just proves that
you know they love that character but
it's not lost on them Catherine O'Hara
is the one that makes that character you
know and I'm actually really glad
because as much as Catherine O'Hara has
done in her career sort of this late on
a show like this on a show with Eugene
Levy who she's worked with you know
throughout her entire life I think for
her to get this next level recognition
from new fans
it is incredible yeah it's funny cuz I
mean yeah it's one thing to say you know
rebus give you lines but it finds so
often the reason that it laughing her
it's just the way she says words yeah
nothing to do it the worse she's saying
how she like an uncertain or puts the
emphasis on certain syllables like it
makes no sense yes absolutely yes it's
going to be interesting to see how they
wrap up the show thing so the show
definitely has linked in toward the
sentimental sign of things I think
that's what fans want to see yeah it's
gonna be interesting to see how they
love because it has even in the last
episode they really set things up of how
I mean I'll see the Sons is
and his wedding thing with hatching and
alexis is supposed to go after New York
and warrior is supposed to be going out
to LA so they've set things everything
up everything I don't know if that's
gonna change in the last uh Heather says
in terms of washing stuff she says I've
never watched this show but I guess I
will spend my summer watching it yeah
it's a good option to watch this summer
can I have two yeah Karen sister Joanie
watched it a few times and that's I mean
the other thing too with shits Creek I
think it was after season 4 that it went
on Netflix and that's what it really
yeah exploded just had been a pop on TV
in the States so it really had each
audience know that thing was around
season four and that's where it really
exploded slower than people were able to
catch up so you know just seeing the fan
base in that show just explode and also
you know and it's an incredible thing
too because people just started getting
attached to it and when they had that
first big push where you saw some real
big stars say that they were fans it was
maybe months later when they announced
that it was ending so so this last push
people were sort of clamoring for it
because they fell in something they fell
in love with something that they knew
just that wasn't going to last and so
they wanted to catch up and so it just
had people the urge to binge this show
suddenly became you know important
viewing because you want it to be caught
up by the end because you wanted to
watch the finale when the rest of the
world did which was just great timing
all around like everything about it was
just perfect Netflix was perfect the
timing was perfect the run of the show
is perfect this isn't something that I
don't think would have been great going
on you know 10 11 12 years and then hey
were you know we've had a decade kind of
thing I think every decision that
they've made with the show has just been
fantastic
yeah something to do with Kathryn about
the ending she was just saying that it's
kind of fitting that this show is any
male because it was a bonus show up of
people all the sudden they were stuck
together in a certain situation and now
we're all kind of yeah yeah save that
guy certain situation so all yeah it
works